ich habe ja diese infektion auch schon
hinter mir ich könne theoretisch könnte
auch eine debatte anfangen ich bin eben
ich brauche jetzt keine maske tragen
aber ist das solidarisch ist das
notwendig ist es so schlimm jetzt ein
paar monate länger diese maske zu tragen
in dem wissen dass die einen schon immun
sind oder eine gewisse immunität
erreicht haben durch impfungen oder auch
durch durchmachen der infektion und die
anderen noch nicht und wo es um es mir
geht ist eben dieser öffentliche bereich
wenn man aus meiner sicht auch keinen
unterschied machen kann wenn es um die
krankenhäuser geht und die rathäuser
geht um den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr geht was anderes ist
ja ob man jemand privat war ja es geht
mir tatsächlich sagen wird das
restaurant dürfen geben stellt wieder
ins restaurant wenn der
restaurantbesitzer sagt geimpfte sind
bei mir herzlich willkommen und es
werden ja hoffentlich schnell von tag zu
tag mehr kommt darf ich als geimpfter
ins restaurant gehen und den nicht
geimpfte muss warten
das ist ja erst mal eine frage im
tatsächlich des privatrechts das gilt ja
für konzerte und andere veranstaltungen
auch und ich finde schon dass da ein
unterschied ist zwischen dem staatlichen
handelns oder eben öffentlicher
daseinsvorsorge u-bahn s-bahn wie
verhalten sich da alle beteiligten oder
ob jemand eben sagt auch in privat
gewerblichen er möchte eben nur für
immune öffnen oder nicht da gibt es
jetzt auch eine diskussion zu die finde
ich übrigens auch durchaus richtig und
wichtig da bin ich allerdings wirklich
auch selber hin und hergerissen in der
in der frage ich finde wir sollten da
nicht zu viel regulieren und irgendwie
jetzt auch eine debatte um kaisers bart
an bestimmten stellen sehr spitzfindig
führen sondern dafür ein ihre
wirtschaftliche existenz aber in
gewissen punkt ich meinte sie ja genau
andersrum eigentlich aber gleichzeitig
eben auch sagen etwa beim maske tragen
da wo man eben vielleicht diesen nicht
unterschied machen auch aushält ohne das
ist eine belastung ist dann auch
entsprechend zu machen und das ist für
mich der entscheidende teil da wo der
staat handelt los und daseinsvorsorge
grundsätzliche angebote geht keinen
unterschied zu machen
bis wir zumindest mal auch allen ein
impfangebot haben machen können und
einen ganz entscheidenden bereichen auch
darüber hinaus machen ja heute an vielen
stellen kein unterschied nach der frage
wie man sich sonst so im leben teil
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren